quick shout out at the beginning letting
you know this video is brought to you by
squarespace the all-in-one platform to
build your online presence and run your
business gonna talk about that a little
more later first got a review movie
based on a disneyland theme park ride
built on the brick and mortar of
dad jokes here we go
so jungle cruise is another attempt by
disney to make a movie based on one of
their properties from their theme park
rides it's like they captured lightning
in a bottle with pirates of the
caribbean they were like all right let's
do that again
and okay again
nice come on so they keep trying so this
is their latest attempt with jungle
cruise so in this movie you have dwayne
the rock johnson and emily blunt on this
swashbuckling adventure as swashbuckling
as it can be it's like
swashbuckling adventure on a river down
the amazon and you do see the dna
of pirates of the caribbean in here you
know you have your creepy
cursed undead army of people i mean it's
a small army in here
but still feels like they were like hey
pirates did it
let's do it like these characters in
here feel like they were pulled from
an unreleased pirates of the caribbean
movie also see some of the dna and
fingerprints of the mummy with brendan
fraser
although those movies are a little more
fleshed out a little more concise a
little less spread thin
but you do see some of that mummy cast
and crew in here you know you have
the lady who knows what she's looking
for her really proper brother that
probably shouldn't be on this dangerous
adventure with her but he is
and the scoundrel who can take them to
where they need to go and they team up
and they go on their adventure
not that the mummy's a masterpiece is
dumb 90s fun and i own the mummy
on vhs just not the weirdest flex i've
done on here but hey
vhs a lot of people think it's just the
movie that takes you back it's not it's
the whole experience you know the shitty
resolution the tracking the crt
the vcr putting the tape in you know
it's all part of it you truly want to go
back in time and get nostalgic with your
entertainment
up your vhs collection and i keep making
that comparison because that's exactly
what this movie feels like that 90s
family action adventure movie that was
supposed to come out in 1999
it's a little late to the party 2021
late to be exact really what carries
this movie is the rock and emily blunt
they actually have good chemistry
together and you feel like you're on a
fun adventure with them they have good
banter back and forth that's comedic
enough but really it's their banter
chemistry it doesn't have to be
funny all the time but you can tell when
two co-stars are making it click on
screen
they do that but i do feel like this
movie was spread a bit more thin in
terms of characters and heroes and
villains than it probably
intended to be so on one hand you have
the dude who plays todd from breaking
bad
he's the german soldier looking for this
magical thing that they're looking for
because it'll help germany win the war
because whether it be world war one
world war
ii any of the world wars german
commanders they search for magic
trinkets that's what they do in movies
so you have him going after them then
you have this group of
cursed soldiers from a few hundred years
ago and
they're also coming after him and i feel
like the cursed soldiers are actually
more important to the plot but i feel
like the german soldier was
there for longer and caused a lot more
problems for them and he was on screen
more so it's like this movie had
villains from two different movies maybe
it initially had the german villain they
were like hey whatever happened to that
pirates of the caribbean movie with
those villains that we never actually
used in the pirates of the
right let's have them in here but it
makes the movie feel a bit spread too
thin like this movie has too much going
on in it common complaint that i
complain about a lot but i can't
remember the last time i watched a movie
where i was like that didn't feel too
long this movie
is like two hours and seven minutes or
something like that for what this movie
is and has going on i feel like that's a
bit too long
hour 45 is probably perfect if i could
choose a villain to cut out it's
probably the german dude
in the u-boat this movie also has bits
that have been done in other movies
before like there's one scene that was
playing out and i was like oh this
reminds me of i've seen this a few times
the movie maverick is a quick go-to that
i mentally just snap to when i see this
bit but in the end this movie is one of
those movies where the main stars really
do
carry the entire thing and even then if
i'm looking at myself like it's not like
i'd be like all right
ticket for one for jungle cruise you
know that may be asking too much but if
you have a family if you're looking for
a fun
family night out you're like hey i want
something that the kids will enjoy that
won't actually bore me to tears
this movie actually does that and
regardless of where it falters if you
have kids i think they'll probably
really enjoy themselves in it
honey you want a night out with the kids
let's all go to a movie jungle cruise
you know how old are the kids
10 to 15. i think they'll have a good
time once again i'll recommend it with
that caveat that i actually
really like it's somewhere between good
time no alcohol required and drunk there
had to be something it is
it's an enjoyable family time no alcohol
required at matinee price and as i
mentioned before this video is brought
to you by squarespace squarespace sells
over 200 top-level domains so you can
find the perfect name for your website
buying a domain on squarespace is easy
throw no hidden fees no price hikes i
appreciate that as well as the fact that
squarespace allows you to present videos
from youtube vimeo and animoto
on your squarespace site and i love the
fact that every design automatically
comes with a unique mobile experience
that matches the overall style of your
website simplicity efficiency
uniformity it's just it's right there
the true all-in-one platform so go to
squarespace.com for your free trial and
when you're ready
to launch click that link below go to
squarespace.com jeremy johns get
yourself 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain using promo code
john's and thank you once again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right so the dad
joke cruise have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you